[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute machen wir eine no
bake kinderregel Torte bzw er
kinderriegelschnitten denn ich liebe
Schnitten über alles von diesen einfach
super praktisch und dieses Rezept geht
auch sehr schnell und sehr einfach und
ihr braucht gar nicht so viele Zutaten
so ich habe jetzt erstmal überlegt bevor
ich um dieses Rezept eingegangen bin bei
Schnitten habe ich immer das Problem wie
sehr wichtig und jetzt habe ich mir
einfach aus dem Schrank irgendwie so
eine Servierplatte geholt und ähm das
ganze mache ich jetzt in meinem
Backrahmen so den Friemel ich mir mal
kurz zusammen und
und da habe ich jetzt gerade mal so die
Maße abgemessen und das ist jetzt gar
nicht so wahnsinnig kompliziert wie sich
das anhört denn bei no-back Rezepten
könnt ihr auch immer gerne variieren
also dadurch dass nichts gebacken wird
seid ihr da so ein bisschen freier und
könnt um ein paar Zentimeter wirklich
variieren so und ich bin jetzt hier
hingegangen und habe erstmal geguckt
okay wie groß soll denn die Schlitten
sein weil ich möchte sie schön
präsentieren die sollen genau auf dieses
Tablet passen und deswegen werden meine
Schnitten 11 cm breit und jetzt habe ich
hier Platz von 40 cm da habe ich mir
gedacht 11 x 40 ist ein bisschen blöd
das geht doch gar nicht aber ich mache
22 x 40 cm na dann gehe ich jetzt hier
an
da ist die 22
einmal Haken dran so und hier bei der 40
mache ich den nächsten Haken dann kann
da auch nichts mehr aufgehen oder
verrutschen so und das sind jetzt meine
Maße für das heutige Rezept wenn ihr das
gerade nicht da habt dann könnt ihr euch
daran orientieren dass ihr so ungefähr
28 x 30 cm braucht an Größe das ganze
geht natürlich auch eine Auflaufform
aber so kriegt einfach die Schnitte
besser geschnitten
Wasser geschnitten oh mein Gott okay wir
starten jetzt mit dem Rezept und zwar
machen wir zuallererst einen Keksboden
also ihr braucht einfach trockene Kekse
das ist einfach Kekse ohne Füllung ich
habe jetzt hier Butterkekse und für
Geschmack aber auch Optik hier diese
spekulose Kekse das sind diese Karamell
Kekse und dann habe ich jetzt hier noch
Butter die ich in der Mikrowelle bei
geringer Wasser schmelzen werde und dann
zeige ich euch wie einfach dieser
Keksboden funktioniert
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Kekse
zerkleinern entweder nehmt ihr euch da
einen ganz großen Beutel zum Beispiel
den Gefrierbeutel gibt die Kekse hier
rein und Haut ganz offen mit dem
Nudelholz drauf und rollt hin und her
bis ihr keine Krümel habt wenn ihr
allerdings einen Mixer habt dann nutzt
gerne den dann wird es auch noch mal ein
bisschen feiner also ich mag beide
Varianten aber die geht einfach
schneller muss ich sagen und wenn ich
das jetzt nicht hätte weil es wirklich
langsam geht würde ich das einfach mit
dem Beutel machen aber so nehme ich
einfach den Mixer mal das fein und geht
das dann zusammen mit Butter in meine
große Schüssel und dann verrühre ich
alles bis nach homogene Masse entsteht
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt der Keksboden einfach in
unserem Backrahmen unten drunter eine
glatte Unterlage drunter legen ich habe
jetzt hier einfach mein Edelstahl
cakeboard sondern kommt das hier rein
und wird richtig schön fest flach
angedrückt entweder nehmt euch einen
Teigschaber oder einfach ein Glas also
da gehen eigentlich viele Wege
hauptsache ihr drückt wirklich fest an
[Musik]
so jetzt machen wir die Milchcreme dafür
benötigen wir kalte Schlagsahne kalte
Mascarpone die hat so einen schönen
neutralen Geschmack
Puderzucker für ein bisschen süßer
Vanilleextrakt weil es einfach sehr
lecker ist und ein bisschen Sahnefest
damit die Creme schön fest wird
wahrscheinlich
der test test was machst du mitten im
Video hier ja wenn weißes Zeug Alter
also auf jeden Fall ist es ja wirklich
immer so ein bisschen Tradition dass wir
es zusammen verkünden eigentlich müsste
jetzt auch schon mal der erste Lounge
war schon da ja es war sehr wo ist das
überhaupt und zwar ich habe auch noch
nehmen
also ich denke jedes mal was soll jetzt
noch kommen immer eine Idee und dann
fangen wir an zu tüfteln und mit Joy ist
eine Milchcreme als Brotaufstrich aber
eigentlich ist viel mehr als ein Bruder
voll der Spoiler Master ich glaube alle
die dir gefallen haben wussten das schon
Monate vorher ich bin da immer sich halt
die Klappe und will euch überraschen auf
jeden Fall ist die mit Joy Creme extrem
lecker sie schmeckt wirklich wie das
Innere von Kinderriegel und daher wollte
genau
wissen genau
immer ein bisschen anders als alle
anderen Firmen deswegen ähm das erinnert
extrem darauf muss ich sagen jetzt ne
das also jetzt habe ich keine Ideen
haben wir doch eine haben
aber ob das realisiert wird weiß ich
noch nicht aber ja ich will gar nicht so
lange geschnacken ich verlinke euch
gerne in die Videobeschreibung kommt
gerne die Augen und ähm genau
gesundes nee wir stehen wir nicht die
ist einfach aus guten Zutaten kein
Palmöl drin nichts was sie nicht
aussprechen können dass es immer so
unsere Devise und sie ist einfach extrem
lecker und unvergleichbar siehst du eine
Marke habe ich noch nie gesehen sein
also das ist wirklich mega cool
bis zu Millimeter hoch gemacht hat das
sind sogar
775 g ich muss noch 25 gleich so
hinterher stehen
aber sind 800 800 Gramm Sahne sind das
ja was anderes
im Shop kaufen
ich benutze die Küchenmaschine ihr könnt
doch euer Handrührgerät verwenden und
ich mache dann ganz einfach
wenn die Zutaten kalt dann könnt ihr
alles zusammen in eine Schüssel geben
und dann erstmal langsam verrühren damit
es zu einer homogenmasse wird und dann
immer schneller werden das Ganze zu
einer festen Masse schlagen also sie
könnte das auch separat machen und so
ist es viel einfacher perfekt kannst du
die Sahne damit rein tun Alter
muss sie kalt sein Sahne 25g Sahne
suchen aber so weggepackt
sein
hier in dem Fall muss es kalt sein oder
so
Puderzucker können wir direkt mit dazu
geben wenn ihr Klümpchen habt aufgrund
von Lagerung gerne sieben was liebe ich
an dir du holst alles rausnehmen ist so
und Vanilleextrakt einfach wegen des
guten Geschmacks braucht auch nicht so
viel besser intensiv ist und dann könnt
ihr von der Milch Joy auch noch was
dazugeben
das ist je nachdem wie es lagert das ist
halt ein Brotaufstrich das sieht man
einfach ja an der Konsistenz wenn ihr es
aber ein bisschen flüssiger haben
möchtet könnt ihr es wieder bei geringer
Wattzahl für 10 15 Sekunden in die
Mikrowelle geben dann könnte
mir echt 360 bis maximum genau
was natürlich immer weniger Sekunden
machen sonst können mich darauf an und
auf jeden Fall ohne Deckel genau also
ich gebe das jetzt so direkt rein und
dann einfach wie gesagt erstmal kurz
verrühren das soll sich alles verbinden
und dann immer schneller werden das
ganze steif schlagen reintun
[Musik]
so das ist die fertige Creme haben so
und ich habe gerade schon gelöffelt die
schmeckt sehr sehr lecker die schmeckt
wirklich wie eine fluffige Kinderriegel
Tortencreme so die kommt jetzt einmal
komplett auf den Boden ihr müsst den
Boden übrigens nicht in den Kühlschrank
stellen ich habe das jetzt einfach nur
so lange ich weiter mache gemacht
einfach damit noch mal der Keksboden
schön sitzt und das ganze noch mal schön
fest wird aber das ganze wird ja eh
später gekühlt daher macht euch da gar
keinen Stress so das ganze werde ich
jetzt noch mal schön glatt verstreichen
und dann kommt bei mir noch eine
Schokoschicht oben drüber weil den
Kinderriegel besteht ja nicht nur aus
der Ultra leckeren weißen Füllung
sondern eben auch aus Schokolade
[Musik]
so für den Guss brauchen wir drei
Zutaten ich habe jetzt hier
Vollmilchkuvertüre die Hacke ich jetzt
erstmal schön fein und dann gebe ich in
meinen Topf hier einfach Sahne und
Butter und wir brauchen einfach diese
Zutaten damit so ein schöner
geschmeidiger groß wird jemand schön
durchschneiden kann das liebe ich ja bei
Schnitten und wichtig ist halt dass ihr
die Sahne nicht hoch kocht also es darf
nicht wirklich hoch kochen und heiß
werden sondern wirklich nur erwärmen und
dann kommt die Schokolade dazu und
dadurch dass wir jetzt eben schön fein
hacken schmilzt sie auch gut und sobald
ihr das dann alles so in den Topf gibt
der ausscheiden und einfach schön
zusammen verbinden lassen und auf euren
Kuchen geben
[Musik]
so bevor wir den Guss jetzt drauf geben
ganz ganz wichtiger Hinweis wartet gerne
noch mal so 10 Minuten dass der ein
bisschen abkühlt weil ihr wisst ja sahne
ist ein bisschen empfindlich was Hitze
angeht also irgendwie voll der
Widerspruch weil Sahne ist auch hier
drin aber ich meine es natürlich so dass
diese Creme ja schön fest bleibt wenn
sie gekühlt ist und wenn da jetzt was
heißt es drauf kommt dann kann es sein
dass die Oberfläche euch ein bisschen
anschmilzt und dann alles zerläuft und
das wollen wir nicht das ist jetzt zehn
vielleicht auch 12 13 Minuten hier
einfach stehen so ein bisschen
runterkühlen und dann gebe ich es ganz
leicht lauwarm auf meine Schnitten
verteil das nur so ein bisschen mit
meiner Palette und dann wird gekühlt
mindestens drei Stunden gerne auch wenn
ihr möchtet länger aber nach drei
Stunden könnt ihr die Schnitten in aller
Ruhe anschneiden ich persönlich werde zu
machen weil da haben sie jetzt einfach
gerade nicht da ist und nicht das
natürlich gerne mit ihm zusammen
probieren möchte mache ich das ganze
über Nacht und wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder das heißt im Umkehrschluss dass
diese Schnitten aber auch sehr lange
haltbar sind also können sie am Vortag
vorbereiten und dann ganze vier Tage
lang essen also sind vier Tage haltbar
also bis morgen
[Musik]
so die Kühlzeit ist um wir können jetzt
erstmal die Schnitten zurecht schneide
ich so und jetzt kommt mein
backformlöser zum Einsatz weil ich
natürlich den Rand hier nicht zerstören
möchte das heißt wenn ihr das einfach so
lösen würdet würdet ihr diese ganze
Glasur mitnehmen und das würde dann
total doof aussehen so einmal lösen dann
den Backrahmen abnehmen und dann wie es
halt anfangs geplant habe in so schöne
lange Schnitten schneiden
[Musik]
ihr braucht keine Sahne aufschlagen weil
ganz ehrlich happy so viel Varianten
müssen immer so ausgetestet auf ein paar
Schnitten gefällt mir nicht aber dann
kam mir eine richtig geniale Idee und
zwar braucht ihr einfach so ein Schäler
und dann könnt ihr hier an der an dem
Riegel entlang stehen bekommt ihr die
schönsten Kinderriegel Deko überhaupt
die schönsten ich wollte eigentlich was
anderes
eingefallen die schönsten normal diese
Dinge
ihr wisst dass ich mein so auf jeden
Fall sieht so richtig traumhaft schön
aus es kommt einfach nur auf die
Oberfläche und ich finde es gibt kein
perfekteren Abschluss für diese
Schnitten als diese Kinderriegel sehr
gespannt
[Musik]
so wir probieren jetzt unsere
kinderriegelschnitten aber das ist
unfair gerade ein bisschen gegessen
du weißt ich liebe sowas
ein Traum
oh sehr lecker
die Creme kommt sehr gut durch muss ich
sagen also die Creme in der Creme es hat
richtig was von kinderriegeln ein
bisschen was von Kinder Joy wenn ich
ehrlich bin voll bei Kinder Joy hast du
ja auch auf der einen Seite Schoko auf
der anderen Seite hell es könnte auch
ein Kinder doll Kuchen sein wenn ich
ehrlich bin einfach diese schokomoos
oben drauf ist so lecker
ja es gehört halt auch dazu aber der
schmeckt total leicht wenn ich ehrlich
bin frisch und leicht also gar nicht
mächtig ganz gefährlich ich könnte
locker locker wirklich mindestens drei
Stück
ausgesprochen
ne also man könnte fast sagen ja dass
man ein bisschen kleiner machen noch
mehr Leute es ist einfach traumhaft also
wirklich unter den Top drei Schnitten
finde ich den wirklich gestern
nein ich finde das heftig wirklich wir
können das jeden Tag essen
verpasst einfach was also schaut euch
unten in der Videobeschreibung die
Zutaten an
Döner gegessen Knoblauchgeruch
gefunden
Bescheid
[Musik]